we had a big day today and don't let
those cheaters and Crooks think anything
different Republican candidates who have
echoed former president Donald Trump's
false claims that the 2020 election was
fraudulent lost some crucial races this
election While others have not yet been
called by the Associated Press
election skeptic candidates were on the
ballot for governor and Secretary of
State across the country on Tuesday but
in a few key swing States these offices
could have the most impact on the 2024
general election and Beyond that's
because Governors and secretaries of
State have considerable authority over
election Administration and in 2020
Nevada Arizona Michigan and Pennsylvania
were all decided by Thin vote margins
here's a breakdown of how election
skeptic candidates fared in each of
those States
this is a movement
[Music]
in Pennsylvania Republican Doug
mastriano was defeated in his race for
governor by Democrat Josh Shapiro
according to the Associated Press as a
state senator mastriano introduced
legislation to ignore the 2020 election
result and directly appoint electors
pledged to Trump despite the fact that
there was no evidence of widespread
fraud and something very near and dear
to both of our hearts we're going to
fight like hell for voting integrity and
we're going to start with voter ID in
Pennsylvania the governor directly
appoints the Secretary of State and
other election officials and therefore
can significantly influence election
policy
foreign
[Music]
why do we have a secretary of state that
wants to go around the rules in Michigan
Republican Tudor Dixon was defeated in
her race for governor by incumbent
Gretchen Whitmer according to the AP
during her campaign Dixon repeated false
claims that the 2020 election result in
Michigan was altered by widespread fraud
if elected she had pledged to enact
strict voter ID laws ban ballot
dropboxes and launch retroactive
investigations into the 2020 election
where is the election is we're Traders
big life proponents for asking questions
and Republican Christina caramo lost her
race for Secretary of State against the
Democratic incumbent Jocelyn Benson
according to the AP
caramo ran on the America First slate of
election Skeptics and has repeated false
claims of election fraud
the Michigan secretary of state does not
have the centralized authority over
election certification that many other
secretaries of State have but he or she
can issue directives to local election
offices and Trigger audits as allies of
President Trump did in 2020.
[Music]
is this the greatest president we've
ever known
in Arizona the governor's race has still
not been called between former TV anchor
Carrie Lake and Democrat Katie Hobbs
Blake was among the most visible and
vocal Skeptics of the 2020 election she
had aligned herself with Trump who made
Arizona a focal point of his false
election claims I'd actually like to ask
everybody on this stage if they would
agree we had a corrupt stolen election
raise your hand
official investigations court cases and
election audits have not substantiated
allegations of widespread fraud
in Arizona the governor and Secretary of
State can enact sweeping changes to
elections especially if their party
controls the state legislature too in
her campaign Lake didn't specify all of
the changes she would make but she
signaled opposition to early voting and
mail-in ballots our constitution says
election day it doesn't say election
season election month the race for
Arizona secretary of state has also not
been called between Republican Mark
fincham and Democrat Adrian Fontes in
Arizona the secretary of state is in
charge of certifying elections as a
state representative fincham introduced
legislation to decertify the 2020
election and during his campaign for
Secretary of State he often repeated
unfounded claims of widespread fraud
there are certain counties that should
have been set aside as irredeemably
compromised Maricopa County was one of
them in Arizona the secretary of state
has broad Powers over election
Administration previously fincham had
expressed a desire to decertify many of
Arizona's election machines
[Music]
your name sir Jim Marchand from Las
Vegas Nevada
we are here to recommend that you vote
today to dispose of your electronic
voting and tabulation machines and do
not use them in any elections going
forward the race for Nevada Secretary of
State has still not been called between
Republican Jim marshan and his
Democratic opponent Cisco Aguilar
Marshawn has made false claims about the
2020 election we have something in
common president Trump and I lost an
election in 2020 because of a rigged
election
ahead of the midterms Marchant LED an
organized campaign to support election
skeptic candidates for Secretary of
State Nationwide last year I established
a mega America First Coalition of
Secretary of State candidates around the
country marshawn's group the America
First slate included a dozen candidates
for Secretary of State and supported the
gubernatorial campaigns of Kerry Lake in
Arizona and Doug mastriano in
Pennsylvania
oh yeah
election skeptic candidates lost some
important bids to take the reins of
election Administration in swing States
While others remain uncalled changes to
election processes in any one of these
states could be the factor that tips a
close election in 2024.